The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Let's start with our
standard starting
point of the last few lectures.
That is, we are
looking at some system.
We tried to describe
it by some kind
of a field, statistical
field after some averaging.
That is, a function of position.
And we are interested
in calculating something
like a partition function
by integrating over
all configurations of
the statistical field.
And these configurations
have some kind of a weight.
This weight we choose
to write as exponential
of some kind of a-- something
like an effective Hamiltonian
that depends on
the configuration
that you're looking at.
And of course, the main
thing faced with a problem
that you haven't seen before is
to decide on what the field is
that you are looking
at to average.
And what kind of
symmetries and constraints
you want to construct in
this form of the weight.
In particular, we
are sort of focusing
on this Landau-Ginzburg
model that
describes phase transitions.
And let's say in the
absence of magnetic field,
we are interested in a system
that is rotationally symmetric.
But the procedure is
reasonably standard.
Maybe in some
cases you can solve
a particular part of this.
Let's call that part beta H0.
In the context that
we are working with,
it's the Gaussian part that
we have looked at before.
So that's the
integral over space.
We used this idea of locality.
We had an expansion
in all things
that are consistent with this.
But for the purposes of
the exactly solvable part,
we focus on the Gaussian.
So there is a term that is
proportional to m squared,
gradient of m squared
and higher-order terms.
So clearly for the
time being, I'm
ignoring the magnetic field.
So let's say in this
formulation the problem that we
are interested is how our
partition function depends
on this coefficient,
which where it goes to 0,
the Gaussian weight becomes
kind of unsustainable.
Now, of course, we said that the
full problem has, in addition
to this beta H0, a part that
involves the interaction.
So what I have done is I
have written the weight
as beta H0 and a part
that is an interaction.
By interaction, I
really mean something
that is not solvable within
the framework of Gaussian.
In our case, what was
non-solvable is essentially
anything-- and there
is infinity of terms--
that don't have
second-order powers of m.
So we wrote terms like m to
the fourth, m to the sixth,
and so forth.
Now, the key to being
able to solve this problem
was to make a transformation
to Fourier modes.
So essentially, what
we did was to write
our m of x as a sum
over Fourier modes.
You could write it, let's
say, in the discrete form as e
to the i q dot x.
And whether I write e to
the i q dot x or minus i q
dot x is not as
important as long as I'm
consistent within
one session at least.
And the normalization
that I used was 1 over V.
And the reason I used
this normalization was
that if I went to the
continuum, I could write it
nicely as an integral
over q divided
by the density of states.
The V would disappear.
e to the i q x m tilde of q.
Now in particular if I
do that transformation,
the Gaussian part simply
becomes 1 over V sum over q.
Then the Fourier
transform of this kernel t
plus k q squared and so forth
divided by 2 m of q discrete
squared.
Which if I go to the
continuum limit simply
becomes an integral
over q t plus k q
squared and so forth
over 2 m of q squared.
Now, once I have the Gaussian
weight, from the Gaussian
weight I can calculate
various averages.
And the averages
are best described
by noting that essentially
after this transformation
I can also write my weight as a
product over the contributions
of the different modes of
something that is of this form,
e to the minus beta H0.
Now written in terms
of these q modes,
clearly it's a product of
independent contributions.
And then of course, there will
be the u to be added later on.
But when I have a product
of independent contributions
for each q, I can immediately
see that if I look at,
say, m evaluated for
some q, m evaluated
for some different q
with the Gaussian weight.
And when I calculate things
with the Gaussian weight,
I put this index 0.
So that's my 0 to order or
exactly solvable theory.
And of course, we are
dealing here with a vector.
So these things have
indices alpha and beta
associated with them.
And if I look at the
discrete version,
I have a product over
Gaussians for each one of them.
Clearly, I will
get 0 unless I am
looking at the same components.
And I'm looking at the same q.
And in particular,
the constraint really
is that q plus q prime
should add up to 0.
And if those constraints
are satisfied,
then I am looking at
the particular term
in this Gaussian.
And the expectation
value of m squared
is simply the variance
that we can see
is V divided by t plus k q
squared, q to the fourth,
and so forth.
And the thing is that most
of the time we will actually
be looking at things directly
in the limit of the continuum
where we replace sums q's
with integrals over q.
And then we have to replace
this discrete delta function
with a continuum delta function.
And the procedure to
do that is that this
becomes delta alpha beta.
This combination
gets replaced by 2 pi
to the d delta function
q plus q prime,
where this is now a
direct delta function
t plus k q squared plus l q
to the fourth and so forth.
And the justification
for doing that is simply
that the Kronecker
delta is defined such
that if I sum over, let's
say, all q, the delta that
is Kronecker, the
answer would be 0.
Now, if I go to the
continuum limit,
the sum over q I have to
replace with integral over q
with a density of states, which
is V divided by 2 pi to the d.
So if I want to replace
this with a continuum delta
function of q, I have to get rid
of this 2 pi to the d over V.
And that's what I have done.
So basically, you
replace-- hopefully I
didn't make a mistake.
Yes.
So the discrete delta I
replace with 1 over V. The V
disappears and the 2
pi to the d appears.
OK?
Now, the thing that
makes some difficulty
is that whereas the rest of
these things that we have not
included as part
of the Gaussian,
because of the locality I
could write reasonably simply
in the space x.
When I go to the space q,
it becomes complicated.
Because each m of x
here I have to replace
with a sum or an integral.
And I have four of those m's.
So here, let's say for the
first term that involves u,
I have in principle to go
over an integral associated
with conversion of the first
m, conversion of the second m,
third m.
Each one of them will carry
a factor of 2 pi to the d.
So there will be three of them.
And the reason I didn't
write the fourth one
is because after I do all
of that transformation,
I will have an integral
over x of e to the i q1
dot x plus q2 dot x plus
q3 dot x plus q4 dot x.
So I have an integral
of e to the i q
dot x where q is the sum
of the four of them over x.
And that gives me
a delta function
that ensures the sum of
the four q's have to be 0.
So basically, one of the
m's will carry now index q1.
The other will carry index q2.
The third will carry index q3.
The fourth will carry index that
is minus q1 minus q2 minus q3.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Does it matter
which indices for squaring it,
or whatever?
Sorry.
Do you need a subscript
for alpha and beta?
PROFESSOR: OK.
That's what I was [INAUDIBLE].
So this m to the fourth is
really m squared m squared,
where m squared is a
vector that is squared.
So I have to put the indices--
let's say alpha alpha--
that are summed
over all possibility
to get the dot product here.
And I have to put
the indices beta
beta to have the
dot products here.
OK?
Now when I go to the
next term, clearly I
will have a whole bunch more
integrals and things like that.
So the e u terms do not
look as nice and clean.
They were local in real space.
But when I go to this Fourier
space, they become non-local.
q's that are all
over this [INAUDIBLE]
are going to be coupled to each
other through this expression.
And that's also why it
is called interaction.
Because in some sense,
previously each q was a mode
by itself and these terms give
interactions between modes that
have different q's.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is there
a way to understand
that physically of why you
get coupling in Fourier space?
[INAUDIBLE] higher
than [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
So essentially, we
have a system that
has translational symmetry.
So when you have
translational symmetry,
this Fourier vector q is
a good conserved quantity.
It's like a momentum.
So one thing that we have
is, in some sense, a particle
or an excitation that
is going by itself
with some particular momentum.
But what these terms represent
is the possibility that you
have, let's say,
two of these momenta
coming and interacting
with each other
and getting two
that are going out.
Why is it [INAUDIBLE]?
It's partly because
of the symmetries
that we built into the problem.
If I had written something
that was m cubed,
I had the possibility
of 2 going to, 1 or 1
going to 2, et cetera.
All right.
I forgot to say one
more thing, which
is that for the Gaussian theory,
I can calculate essentially
all expectation values
most [INAUDIBLE]
in this context of the
Fourier representation.
So this was an
example of something
that had two factors of m.
But very soon, we will see
that we would need terms
that, let's say, involve
m factors of n that
are multiplied each other.
So I have m alpha i of
qi-- something like that.
And again, 0 for the
Gaussian expectation value.
And if I have written things
the way that I have-- that is,
I have no magnetic field.
So I have m2 minus
m symmetry, clearly
the answer is going
to be 0 if l is odd.
If l is even, we have this
nice property of Gaussians
that we described
in 8.333, which
is that this will be the sum
over all pairs of averages.
So something like
m1, m2, m3, m4.
You can have m1 m2
multiplying by m3 m4 average.
m1 m3 average multiply
m2 m4 average.
m1 m4 average multiplied
by m2 m3 average.
And this is what's called
a Wick's theorem, which
is an important property of
the Gaussian that we will use.
So we know how to calculate
averages of things of interest,
which are essentially product
of these factors of m,
in the Gaussian theory.
Now let's calculate
these averages
in perturbation theory.
So quite generally, if I want to
calculate the average of some O
in a theory that involves
averaging over some function
l-- so this could be some
trace, some completely
unspecified things-- of a
weight that is like, say,
e to the minus beta H0.
A part that I can
do and a part that I
want to treat as a small
change to what I can do.
The procedure of
calculating the average
is to multiply the
probability by the quantity
that I want to average.
And of course, the whole thing
has to be properly normalized.
And this is the normalization,
which is the partition function
that we had previously.
Now, the whole idea
of perturbation
is to assume that this
quantity u is small.
So we start to expand
e to the minus u.
I can certainly do
that very easily,
let's say, in the denominator.
I have e to the minus
beta H0, and then I
have 1 minus u plus u squared
over 2 minus u cubed over 6.
Basically, the usual
expansion of the exponential.
In the numerator, I
have the same thing,
except that there is an
I that is multiplying
this expansion for the
operator, or the object that I
want to calculate the average.
Now, the first term that I
have in the denominator here,
1 multiplied by all integrals
of e to the minus H0
is clearly what I would
call the partition function,
or the normalization
that I would
have for the Gaussian weight.
So that's the first term.
If I factor that out,
then the next term
is u integrated against
the Gaussian weight
and then properly normalized.
So the next term will be the
average of u with the Gaussian
or whatever other
0 to order weight
is that I can calculate things
and I have indicated that by 0.
And then I would
have 1/2 average
of u squared 0 and so forth.
And the series in the numerator
once I factor out the Z0
is pretty much the same except
that every term will have an o.
The Z 0's naturally
I can cancel out.
So what I have is
from the numerator o
minus ou plus 1/2 ou squared.
What I will do with
the denominator
is to bring it in the
numerator regarding
all of these as
a small quantity.
So if I were to essentially
write this expression raised
to the minus 1 power, I
can make a series expansion
of all of these terms.
So the first thing, if I
just had one over 1 minus u
in the denominator,
it would come
from 1 plus u plus u squared
and u cubed, et cetera.
But I've only kept thing
to order of u squared.
So when I then
correct it because
of this thing in
the denominator,
the 1/2 becomes minus
1/2 u squared 0.
And then, there will be
order of u cubed terms.
So the answer is the
product of two brackets.
And I can reorganize that
product, again, in powers of u.
The lowest-order term
is the 0 to order,
or unperturbed average.
And the first correction
comes from ou average.
And then I have the
average of u average of u.
You can see that something
like a variance or connected
correlation or cumulant
appears because I
have to subtract
out the averages.
And then the next order
term, what will I have?
I will write it as 1/2.
I start with ou squared 0.
Then I can multiply
this with this,
so I will get minus 2 o u0 u0.
And then I can multiply
o0 with those two terms.
So I will have minus o0
u squared 0 plus 2 o0--
this is over here.
u0 squared and
higher-order terms.
So basically, we can see
that the coefficients,
as I have written, are going to
be essentially the coefficients
that I would have if I were
to expand the exponential.
So things like minus 1 to
the n over n factorial.
And the leading
term in all cases
is o u raised to
the n-th power 0,
out of which are
subtracted various things.
And the effect of
those subtractions,
let's say we define
a quantity which
is likely cumulants that we were
using in 8.333, which describe
the subtractions that you would
have to define such an average.
So that's the general structure.
What this really
means-- and I sometimes
call it cumulant or connected--
will become apparent
very shortly.
This is the general result.
We have a particular
case above, which
is this Landau-Ginzburg theory
perturbed around the Gaussian.
So let's calculate the simplest
one of our averages, this m
alpha of q m beta of q prime,
not at the Gaussian level,
but as a perturbation.
And actually, for
practical reasons,
I will just calculate the
effect of the first term, which
is u m to the fourth.
So I will expand in powers of u.
But once you see
that, you would know
how to do it for m to the sixth
and all the higher powers.
So according to
what we have here,
the first term is
m alpha of q m beta
of q prime evaluated
with the Gaussian theory.
The next term, this one,
involves the average
of this entity and the u.
So our u I have
written up there.
So I have minus
from the first term.
The terms that are
proportional to u,
I will group together
coming from here.
u itself involved this
integration over q1 q2 q3.
And u involves
this m i of q1 m i
of q2 mj of q3 mj of minus
q1 minus q2 minus q3.
And I have to multiply it.
So this is u.
I have to multiply it by o.
So I have m alpha of
q m beta of q prime.
So this is my o.
This is my u.
And I have to take the
average of this term.
But really, the average
operates on the m's,
so it will go over here.
So that's the average of ou.
I have to subtract from that
the average of o average of u.
So let me, again,
write the next term.
u will be the same
bunch of integrations.
I have to do average of
o and then average of u.
This completes my first
correction coming from u,
and then there will be
corrections to first order
coming from V. There will be
second-order corrections coming
from u squared,
all kinds of things
that will come into play.
But the important thing, again,
to realize is the structure.
u is this thing that
involves four factors of m.
The averages are
over the m, so I
can take them
within the integral.
And so I have one case which
is an expectation value of six
m's.
Another case, a product of
two and a product of four.
So that's why I
said I would need
to know how to calculate
in the Gaussian theory
product of various factors
of m because my interaction
term involves various powers
of m that will be added
to whatever expectation value
I'm calculating perturbation
theory.
So how do I calculate
an expectation
that involves six factors--
certainly, it's even-- of m?
I have to group-- make
all possible pairings.
So this, for example,
can be paired to this.
This can be paired to this.
That's a perfectly
well-defined average.
But you can see
that if I do this,
if I pair this one,
this one, this one,
I will get something that will
cancel out against this one.
So basically, you can
see that any way that I
do averaging that involves only
things that are coming from o
and separately the
things that come from u
will cancel out with the
corresponding-- oops.
With the corresponding
averages that I do over here.
That c stands for connected.
So the only things that survive
are pairings or contractions
that pick something
that is from o
and connect it to
something that is from u.
And the purpose of all of
these other terms at all higher
orders is precisely
to remove pieces
where you don't have full
connections among all
of the o's and the u's
that you are dealing with.
So let's see what this is.
So I will show you that using
connections that involve both o
and u, I will have two types of
contractions joining o and u.
The first type is
something like this.
I will, again, draw all-- or
write down all of the fours.
So I have m alpha of q m beta of
q prime m i of q1 m i of q2 mj
of q3 mj of minus q1
minus q2 minus q3.
I have to take that average.
And I do that the
average according
to Wick's theorem as a
product of contractions.
So let's pick this m alpha.
It has to ultimately be
paired with somebody.
I can't pair it with
m beta because that's
a self-contraction and
will get subtracted out.
So I can pick any
one of these fours.
As far as I'm concerned,
all four are the same,
so I have a choice of four
as to which one of these four
operators from u I connect to.
So that 4 is one of
the numerical factors
that ultimately we
have to take care of.
Then, the two types
comes because the next m
that I pick from o I
have two possibilities.
I can connect it either with the
partner of the first one that
also carries index
i or I can connect
to one of the things that
carries the opposite index j.
So let's call type 1 where
I make the choice that I
connect to the partner.
And once I do that,
then I am forced
to connect these two together.
Now, each one of these pairings
connects one of these averages.
So I can write
down what that is.
So the first one connected an
alpha to an i as far as indices
were concerned.
It connected q to q1, so I have
2 pi to the d a delta function
q plus q1.
And the variance
associated with that,
which is t plus k q
squared, et cetera.
The second pairing
connects a beta to an i.
So that's a delta beta i.
And it connects q prime to q2.
And so the variance
associated with that
is t plus k q prime
squared and so forth.
And finally, the third pairing
connects j to itself j.
So I will get a delta jj.
And then I have 2 pi to the d.
q3 to minus q1
minus q2 minus q3.
So I will get minus
q1 minus q2, and then
I have t plus, say, k
q3 squared and so forth.
Now, what I am supposed to
do is at the next stage,
I have to sum over indices i and
j and integrate over q1 q2 q3.
So when I do that,
what do I get?
There is an overall
factor of minus u.
Let's do the indices.
When I sum over i, delta
alpha i delta beta i
becomes-- actually, let
me put the factor of 4
before I forget it.
There is a factor
of 4 numerically.
Delta alpha i delta beta i will
give me a delta alpha beta.
When I integrate over
q1, q1 is set to minus q.
So this after the
integration becomes q.
When I integrate
over q2, the delta
function q2 forces
minus q2 to be q prime.
And through the process, two of
these factors of 2 pi to the d
disappear.
So what I'm left with
is 2 pi to the d.
This delta function now
involves q plus q prime.
And then in the denominator,
I have this factor of t
plus k q squared.
I have t plus k q prime squared.
Although, q prime squared
and q squared are the same.
I could have collapsed
these things together.
I have one integration
left over q3.
And these two
factors went outside
the integral [INAUDIBLE]
independent q3.
The only thing
that depends on q3
is t plus k q3
squared and so forth.
So that was easy.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: If you're summing
over j, won't you get an n?
PROFESSOR: Thank you very much.
I forgot the delta jj.
Summing over j, I will
get a factor of n.
So what I had written
here as 4 should be 4n.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: This may be a
question too far back.
But when you write a correlation
between two different m's,
why do you write
delta function of q
plus q prime instead
of q minus q prime?
PROFESSOR: OK.
Again, go back all
the way to here
when we were doing
the Gaussian integral.
I will have for
the first one, q1.
For the second m,
I will write q2.
So when I Fourier
transform this term,
I will have e to the
i q1 plus q2 dot x.
And then when I
integrate over x,
I will get a delta
function q1 plus q2.
So that's why I write all
of these as absolute value
squared because I
could have written this
as m of q m of minus q, but
I realized that m of minus q
is the complex
conjugate of m of q.
So all of these are
absolute values squared.
Now, the second class of
contraction is-- again,
write the same thing, m alpha of
q m beta of q prime m i of q1 m
i of q2, mj of q3 mj of
minus q1 minus q2 minus q3.
The first step is the same.
I pick m alpha of q and I
have no choice but to pick
one of the four
possibilities that I have
for the operators
that appear in u.
But for the second
one, previously I
chose to connect it
to something that
was carrying the same index.
Now I choose to
carry it to something
that carries the other
index, j in this case.
And there are two things
that carry index j,
so I have two choices there.
And then I have the remaining
two have to be connected.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Just going
back a little bit.
Are you assuming that
your integral over q3
converges because you're
only integrating over
the [INAUDIBLE] zone?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
Any time I see a
divergent integral,
I have a reason to
go back to my physics
and see why physics
will avoid infinities.
And in this case, because
all of my theories
have an underlying length
scale associated with them
and there is an
associated maximum value
that I can go in Fourier space.
The only possible
singularities that I
want to get are coming
from q goes to 0.
And again, if I really want
to physically cut that off,
I would put the
size of the system.
But I'm interested in systems
that become infinite in size.
So the first term for this
way of contracting things
is as follows.
There are eight such terms.
I should have really
put the four here.
There are eight such
types of contractions.
Then I have a delta alpha
i 2 pi to the d delta
function q plus q1 divided by t
plus k q squared and so forth.
The first contraction is
exactly the same as before.
The next contraction I connect
i to j and q prime to q3.
So I have a delta beta j 2
pi to the d delta function q
prime going to q3 divided
by t plus k q prime squared
and so forth.
And the last contraction
connects an i to a j.
Delta ij.
I have 2 pi to the d.
Connecting q2 to minus
q1 minus q2 minus q3
will give me a delta function
which is minus q1 minus q3.
And then I have t plus k-- I
guess in this case-- q2 squared
and so forth.
So once more sum ij.
Integrate q1 q2 q3 and
let's see what happens.
So again, it's a term that
is proportional to minus u.
The numerical coefficient
that it carries is 8.
And there is no n here
because when I sum over i,
you can see that j is set
to be the same as alpha.
Then when I sum over j, I set
alpha to be the same as beta.
So there is just a
delta alpha beta.
When I integrate over
q1, q1 is set to minus q.
q3 is set to minus q prime.
So this factor becomes the
same as q plus q prime.
And the two variances,
which are in fact the same,
I can continue to write
as separate entities
but they're really
the same thing.
And then the one
integral that is
left-- I did q1 and Q3--
it's the integral over q2,
2 pi to the d 1 over t plus
K q2 squared and so forth.
It is, in fact, exactly
the same integral
as before, except that the
name of the dummy integration
variable has changed from
q2 to q3, or q3 to q2.
So we have calculated m
alpha of q m beta of q prime
to the lowest order in
perturbation theory.
To the first order, what I
had was a delta alpha beta 2
pi to the d delta function
q plus q prime divided by t
plus k q squared.
Now, note that all
of these factors
are present in the
two terms that I
had calculated as corrections.
So I can factor this
out and write it
as the correction as 1
plus or minus something.
It is proportional to u.
The coefficient is
4n plus 8, which
I will write as 4 n plus 2.
I took out one factor
of t plus k q squared.
There is one factor
that's will be remaining.
Therefore, t plus k q squared.
And then I have one
integration over some variable.
Let's call it k.
It doesn't matter what I call
the integration variable.
1 over t plus k, k
squared, and so forth.
And presumably, there will
be higher-order terms.
Now again, I did the
calculation specifically
for the Landau-Ginzburg,
but the procedure you
would have been able to
do for any field theory.
You could have
started with a part
that you can solve
exactly and then
look at perturbations
and corrections.
Now, there is, in
fact, a reason why
this correction
that we calculated
had exactly the same
structure of delta functions
as the original one.
And why I anticipate that
higher-order terms, if I were
to calculate, will
preserve that structure.
And the reason has to
do with symmetries.
Because quite generally, I
can write for anything-- m
alpha m beta of q prime without
doing perturbation theory.
Again, let's remember
m alphas of q
are going to be related to
m of x by inverse Fourier
transformation.
So m alpha of q I can write
an integral d dx e to the-- I
guess by that convention, it
has to be minus i q dot x.
m alpha of x.
And again, m beta
of q prime I can
write as minus i q
prime dot x prime.
And I integrate
also over an x prime
of m alpha of x m
beta of x prime.
Now, these are evaluated in
real space as opposed to Fourier
space.
And the average goes over here.
At this stage, I
don't say anything
about perturbation theory,
Gaussian, et cetera.
What I expect is that
this is a function,
that in a system that has
translational symmetry, only
depends on x minus x prime.
m beta.
Furthermore, in a system that
has rotational symmetry that
is not spontaneously
broken, that
is approaching from the
high temperature side,
then just rotational
symmetry forces you
that-- the only
tensor that you have
has to be proportional
to delta alpha beta.
So I can pick some particular
component-- let's say m1--
and I can write it
in this fashion.
So the rotational symmetry
explains the delta alpha beta.
Now, knowing that the function
that I'm integrating over two
variables actually only depends
on the relative position
means that I can re-express
this in terms of the relative
and center of mass coordinates.
So I can express
that expression as e
to the minus i q minus q
prime x minus x prime over 2.
And then I will
write it as minus i
q plus q prime x
plus x prime over 2.
If you expand those, you will
see that all of the cross terms
will vanish and I will get q
dot x and q prime dot x prime.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Thank you.
So now I can change
integration variables
to the relative coordinate and
the center of mass coordinate
rather than integrating
over x and x prime.
The integration over the
center of mass, the x plus x
prime variable, couples
to q plus q prime.
So it will immediately
tell me that the answer has
to be proportional
to q plus q prime.
I had already established that
there is a delta alpha beta.
So the only thing that is
left is the integration
over the relative coordinate
of e to the minus i
some q-- either one of them.
q dot r.
Since q prime is minus q,
I can replace it with e
to the i q dot the
relative coordinate.
m1 of r m1 of 0.
So that's why for a system
that has translational symmetry
and rotational
symmetry, this structure
of the delta functions
is really imposed
for this type of
expectation value.
Naturally, perturbation
theory has to obey that.
But then, this is a quantity
that we had encountered before.
If you recall when
we were scattering
light out of the
system, the amplitude
of something that was
scattered was proportional
to the Fourier transform of
the correlation function.
And furthermore,
in the limit where
S is evaluated for q equal
to 0, what we are doing
is we're essentially integrating
the correlation function.
We've seen that the integrals
of correlation function
correspond to the
susceptibilities.
So you may have thought
that what I was calculating
was a two-point correlation
function in perturbation
theory.
But what I was
actually leading up to
is to know what the
result is for scattering
from this theory.
And in some limit
of it, I've also
calculated what the
susceptibility is,
how the susceptibility
is corrected.
And again, if you recall
the typical structure
that people see for
S of q is that S of q
is something like 1 over
something like this.
This is the
Lorentzian line shapes
that we had in scattering.
And clearly, the
Lorentzian line shape
is obtained by Fourier
transformation and expectation
values of these
expansions that we make.
So it kind of makes
sense that rather
than looking at this quantity,
I should look at its inverse.
So I have calculated
s of q, which
is the formula that
I have up there.
So this whole thing
here is S of q.
If I calculate its
inverse, what do I get?
First of all, I
have to invert this.
I have t plus k q squared, which
is what would have given me
the Lorentzian if I
were to invert it.
And now we have found the
correction to the Lorentzian
if you like, which
is this object raised
to the power of minus 1.
But recall that I've
only calculated things
to lowest order in u.
So whenever I see something
and I'm inverting it
just like I did
over here, I better
be consistent to order of u.
So to order of u, I can take
this thing from the numerator,
bring it to the num--
from denominator
to numerator at the expense
of just changing the sign.
Order of u squared
that we haven't really
bothered to calculate.
So now it's nice because you
can see that when I expand this,
this factor will
cancel that factor.
So the inverse has the
structure that we would like.
It is t plus something
that is a constant,
doesn't depend on
q, 4 n plus 2 u.
Well, actually, no.
Yeah.
Because this denominator
gets canceled.
I will get 4 n plus 2
u integral over k 2 pi
to the d 1 over t plus k
k squared and so forth.
And then I have my k q squared.
And presumably, I will
have higher-order terms
both in u and higher
powers of q, et cetera.
And in particular, the
inverse of the susceptibility
is simply the first part.
Forget about the k q squared.
So the inverse of
susceptibility is
t plus 4 n plus 2 u integral
d dk 2 pi to the d 1 over t
plus k k squared and so forth.
Plus order of things
that we haven't computed.
So why is it interesting
to look at susceptibility?
Because susceptibility is
one of the quantities--
it always has to be positive--
that we were associating
previously with
singular behavior.
And in the absence of the
perturbative correction
from the Gaussian,
the susceptibility
we calculated many times.
It was simply 1 over t.
If I had added a
field, the field h
would have changed
the free energy
by an amount that would be
h squared over 2t as we saw.
Take two derivatives,
I will get 1
over t for the susceptibility.
So the 0 order sustainability
that I will indicate by chi sub
0 was something that was
diverging at t equals to 0.
And we were identifying
the critical exponent
of the divergence as
gamma equals to 1.
So here, I would have
added gamma 0 equals to 1.
Because of the
linear divergence--
and the linear divergence
can be traced back
to the linearity
of the vanishing
of the inverse susceptibility
at temperature.
Now, let's see whether we
have calculated a correction
to gamma.
Well, the first
thing that you notice
that if I evaluated the new chi
inverse at 0, all I need to do
is to put 0 in this formula.
I will get 4 n plus 2 u.
This integral d dk 2 pi to
the d 1 over k k squared.
I set t equals to 0 here.
Now this is, indeed, an integral
that if I integrate all the ay
to infinity would diverge on me.
I have to put an upper cutoff.
It's a simple integral.
I can write it as
integral 0 to lambda dk
k to the d minus 1 with some
surface of a d dimensional
sphere.
I have this 2 pi
to the d out front
and I have a k squared here.
I can put the k out here.
So you can see that this is an
integral that's just a power.
I can simply do that.
The answer ultimately will be
4 n plus 2 u Sd 2 pi to the d.
There is a factor of 1 over
k that comes into play.
The integral of
this will give me
the upper cutoff to the d
minus 2 divided by d minus 2.
So what we find is that the
corrected susceptibility
to lowest order does not
diverge at t equals to 0.
Its inverse is a finite value.
So actually, you
can see that I've
added something positive
to the denominator
so the value of susceptibility
is always reduced.
So what does that mean?
Does that mean that the
susceptibility does not
have a singularity anymore?
The answer is no.
It's just that the location of
the singularity has changed.
The presence of
u m to the fourth
gives some additional stiffness
that you have to overcome.
t equals to 0 is not
sufficient for you.
You have to go to
some other point tc.
So I expect that this
thing will actually
diverge at a new point
tc that is negative.
And if it diverges, then
its inverse will be 0.
So I have to solve the
equation tc plus 4 n
plus 2 u integral d dk 2 pi
to the d of 1 over tc plus k
k squared and so forth.
So this seems like an implicit
[INAUDIBLE] equation in tc
because I have to evaluate the
integral that depends on tc,
and then have to set
that function to 0.
But again, we have calculated
things only correctly
to order of u.
And you can see already that
tc is proportional to u.
So this answer here is something
that is order of u presumably.
And a u compared
to the u out front
will give me a correction
that is order of u squared.
So I can ignore this
thing that is over here.
So to order of u, I know
that tc is actually minus
what I had calculated before.
So I get that tc is
minus this 4 n plus 2 u k
Sd lambda to the d minus
2 2 pi to the d d minus 2.
It doesn't matter what it is,
it's some non-universal value.
Point is that, again,
the location of the phase
transition certainly will
depend on the parameters
that you put in your theory.
We readjusted our theory
by putting m to the fourth.
And certainly, that will change
the location of the transition.
So this is what we found.
The location of the
transition is not universal.
However, we kind
of hope and expect
that the singularity, the
divergence of susceptibility
has a form that is universal.
There is an exponent that
is characteristic of that.
So asking the question of
how these corrected chi
divergence diverges
at this tc is the same
as asking the question of how
its inverse vanishes at tc.
So what I am interested
is to find out
what the behavior of chi inverse
is in the vicinity of the point
that it goes to 0.
So basically, what
this singularity is.
This is, of course, 0.
By definition, chi
inverse of tc is 0.
So I am asking how chi vanishes
its inverse when I approach tc.
So I have the formula for
chi once I substitute t,
once I substitute tc
and I subtract them.
To lowest order I
have t minus tc.
To next order, I have this 4 u
n plus 2 integral over k 2 pi
to the d.
I have for chi inverse of t 1
over t plus k k squared minus 1
over tc plus k k squared.
And terms that I
have not calculated
are certainly
order of u squared.
Now, you can see that
if I combine these two
into the same denominator
that is the product,
in the numerator I will
get a factor of t minus tc.
The k q squareds cancel.
So I can factor out this t
minus tc between the two terms.
Both terms vanish
at t equals to tc.
And then I can look at
what the correction is
to one, just like I did before.
The correction is going
to-- actually, this
will give me tc minus t,
so I will have a minus 4 u
n plus 2 integral
d dk 2 pi to the d.
The product of two of these
factors, t plus k-- tc plus k k
squared t plus k k squared,
and then order of u squared.
OK?
Happy with that?
Now again, this tc we've
calculated is order of u.
And consistently, to calculate
things to order of u,
I can drop that.
And again, consistently to
doing things to order of u,
I can add a tc here.
And that's also a correction
that is order of u.
And this answer
would not change.
The justification of
why I choose to do that
will become apparent
shortly, but it's consistent
that this is left.
So what I find at
this stage is that I
need to evaluate an
integral of this form.
And again, with all
of these integrals,
we better take a look as to
what the most significant
contribution to the integral is.
And clearly, if I
look at k goes to 0,
there are various
factors out there
that as long as t
minus tc is positive,
I will have no worries
because this k squared
will be killed off
by factors of k
to the d minus 1 in
dimensions above 2.
But if I go to large
k-values, I find
that large k-values,
the singularity
is governed by k to
the power of d minus 4.
So as long as I'm
dealing with things
that have some upper
cutoff, I don't
have to worry about it even
in dimensions greater than 4.
In dimensions
greater than 4, what
happens is that the
integral is going
to be dominated by the
largest values of k.
But those largest values of
k will be cutoff by lambda.
The answer ultimately
will be proportional to 1
over k squared, and then k
to the power of d minus 4
replaced by lambda
to the d minus 4--
various overall coefficient
of d minus 4 or whatever.
It doesn't matter.
On the other hand, if you go
to dimensions less than 4--
again, larger than
2, but I won't
write that for the time being--
then the behavior at large k
is perfectly convergent.
So you are integrating
a function that goes up,
comes down.
You can extend the integration
all the way to infinity,
end up with a definite integral.
We can rescale all
of our factors of k
to find out what that definite
integral is dependent on.
And essentially, what it does
is it replaces this lambda
with the characteristic value
of k that corresponds roughly
to the maximum.
And that's going to
occur at something
like t minus tc over
k to the power of 1/2.
So I will get d minus 4 over 2.
There is some overall definite
integral that I have to do,
which will give me some
numerical coefficient.
But at this time,
let's forget about
the numerical coefficient.
Let's see what the structure is.
So the structure then
is that chi inverse
of t, the singularity
that it has
is t minus tc to the 0 order.
Same thing as you would have
predicted for the Gaussian.
And then we have a
correction, which
is this minus something that
goes after all of these things
with some coefficient.
I don't care what
that coefficient is.
u n plus 2 divided by k squared.
And then multiplied by lambda
to the power of d minus 4,
or t minus tc over k to the
power of d minus 4 over 2.
And then presumably,
higher-order terms.
And whether you have
the top or the bottom
will depend on d greater
than 4 or d less than 4.
So you see the problem.
If I'm above four
dimensions, this term
is governed by the upper cutoff.
But the upper cutoff
is just some constant.
So all that happens
is that the dependence
remains as being
proportional to t minus tc.
The overall amplitude
is corrected
by something that depends on u.
You are not worried.
You say that the leading
singularity is the same thing
as I had before.
Gamma will stay to be 1.
I try to do that in less
than four dimensions
and I find that as I approach
tc, the correction that I had
actually itself
becomes divergent.
So now I have to throw out
my entire perturbation theory
because I thought I was making
an expansion in quantity
that I can make
sufficiently small.
So in usual perturbation
theory, you say
choose epsilon less than 10
to the minus 100, or whatever,
and then things will
be small correction
to what you had at 0 order.
Here, I can choose my u
to be as small as I like.
Once I approach tc, the
correction will blow up.
So this is called a divergent
perturbation theory.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So could we have
known a priori that we couldn't
get a correction to gamma
from the perturbation theory
because the only way
for gamma to change
is for the correction
to have a divergence?
PROFESSOR: You are presuming
that that's what happens.
So indeed, if you
knew that there
is a divergence with an exponent
that is larger than gamma,
you probably could
have guessed that you
wouldn't get it this way.
Let's say that we are choosing
to proceed mathematically
without prior knowledge of what
the experimentalists have told
us, then we can
discover it this way.
AUDIENCE: I was
thinking if you're
looking for how gamma changes
due to the higher-order things,
if we found that our
perturbation diverged
with a lower
exponent than gamma,
then the leading one
would still be there,
original gamma would be gone.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: And then
if it's higher,
then we have the same problem.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
So the problem that
we have is actually
to somehow make sense of this
type of perturbation theory.
And as you say, it's correct.
We could have actually guessed.
And I'll give you another
reason why the perturbation
theory would not have worked.
But the only thing
that we can really do
is perturbation
theory, so we have
to be clever and figure
out a way of making sense
of this perturbation theory,
which we will do by combining
it with the normalization group.
But a better way or another
way to have seen maybe
why this does not work is
good old-fashioned dimensional
analysis.
I have within the exponent of
the weight that I wrote down
terms that are of this formula,
t m squared k gradient of m
squared u m to the
fourth and so forth.
Since whatever is in
the exponent should
be dimensionless-- I usually
write beta H for example--
we know that this t
has some dimension.
Square the dimension of m
multiplied by length to the d.
This should be dimensionless.
Similarly, k m squared again.
Because of the gradient
l to the d minus 2,
that combination should
be dimensionless.
And my u m to the fourth l to
the d should be dimensionless.
So we can get rid of the
dimensions of m by dividing,
let's say, u m to the fourth
with the square of k m squared.
So we can immediately
see that u divided by k
squared, I get rid of
the dimensions of m.
l to the power of d
l to the 2d minus 4,
giving me l to the 4
minus d is dimensionless.
So any perturbation theory that
I write down ultimately where
I have some quantity x,
which is at 0 order 1,
and then I want to make a
correction where u appears,
I should have
something, u over k
squared, and then some power of
length to make the dimensions
work out.
So what lengths do I
have available to me?
One length that I have is
my microscopic length a.
So I could have put here a
to the power of 4 minus d.
But there is also
an emergent length
in the problem, which is
the correlation length.
And there is no reason why
the dimensionless form that
involves the correlation
length should not appear.
And indeed, what we have
over here to 0 order,
our correlation length had
the exponent 1/2 divergence.
So this is really the 0
order correlation length
that is raised to the
power of 4 minus d.
So even before doing
the calculation,
we could have guessed
on dimensional ground
that it is quite possible
that we are expanding in u,
we think.
But at the end of the day,
we are expanding in u c
to the power of 4 minus d.
And there is no way that that's
a small quantity on approaching
the phase transition.
And that hit us on
the face and also is
the reason why I replaced this
t over here with t minus tc
because the only place where I
expect singularities to emerge
in any of these
expansions is at tc.
I arranged things so they would
appear at the right place.
So should we throw out
perturbation theory completely
since the only
thing that we can do
is really perturbation theory?
Well, we have to
be clever about it.
And that's what we
will do next lectures.